whack was on clubhouse talking about how
you would never sign a sider um did you
see that um i heard about it i didn't
really pay too much attention to it i
talked to him about it a bit he was just
like you know i obviously have mexicans
i've signed he's like but i was locked
up for x amount of years and you know we
were at war and like
i couldn't sign this outsider because
my comrades that are still incarcerated
would look at me a certain way right um
was that like like is that something
that as you know because i i feel like
i guess i never i didn't grow up in l.a
so i guess like the beef between blacks
and mexicans was something i never
really witnessed because it was never
something that happened in phoenix where
i'm from
but how serious like in prison like you
guys are enemies right i mean
in prison there's like there's a whole
new set of rules
nobody's really your enemy other than
you know what i mean it's just things
happen while you're in there and it
could be with the officers it could be
with another race it can be with whoever
it's not
one certain crowd that you don't
like and wake up and and say hey i hate
these people because if you hate
somebody
they're right across the day room from
you you can go get them there's no oh i
hate them but they can stay on their
side of the day room i'll stay on my
don't work like that if i hate somebody
i'm coming for you you know what i mean
and
as far as what you know whack 100 said
you know i i feel like every man has
their own opinion or every man has their
own choice if that's what he chooses
that's his opinion so be it you know
there's
people from
our side you know hispanics that don't
like blacks and that's their decision
you know what i'm saying like that's
their opinion it's just all it's just
all part of you know being a man and
taking these
these um
these like uh how can i say like
stop taking everything to the heart man
you know what i'm saying at the end of
the day just
roll with whatever's going on and
do you
do you do you feel like it was uh hard
for you uh at any point in time to like
leave behind that prison mind state
maybe like leave behind some of the
ideas and the politics that go into
being locked up in a position that
you're in and like and then also get out
be a free man try to stay on the right
track and also
succeed in as an as an artist right well
it's always hard
being the fact that you know one thing i
can't give up is my homies i love my
homies you know and i still you know
associate communicate whatever you want
to call it with some of them that are
family basically they grew to be family
over the years
it's like it's not about
us going to go look and try to find an
enemy now or oh it's us trying to sell
drugs now like now it's just hey what's
up my boy how you doing oh look today i
did this i did this music i did that so
like the the good thing about my homies
is they respect what i'm doing they
appreciate what i'm doing and you know
they still got love from me they haven't
switched up they haven't
you know basically like i've seen other
you know artists that are from certain
gangs that they can't go to their
neighborhood because their homies don't
[ __ ] with them like that you know what i
mean my homies do and that's a blessing
you know what i mean and they see what
i'm doing they see that i'm doing
something positive and they they respect
it